[Musique]
mais bon
bâle est tiens il y a deux espèces
menacées là vous pouvez les voir là ces
deux grosses oiseaux ce sont des espèces
très menacées
m'a dit là il fait un militant de la
cause animale comme chaque vendredi
matin il vadrouille dans le principal
marché aux animaux de bagdad pour
repérer les espèces menacées ou
vulnérables qui ne sont pas censés être
vendus ici
encore une espèce en danger ici
tu penses à combien 85 mille dinars et
léger 50 euros
la chasse de cette espèce est illégale
en irak ça va aussi
regarder il y en a d'autres dans cette
boîte il y en a quatre
victimes du braconnage ces oiseaux
conservé dans des conditions pour le
moins inadéquate sont très prisés des
irakiens les lois nationales en
interdisent la chasse et le commerce
mais il est très facile de trouver ces
espèces dans les marchés à bagdad police
la police ils viennent ici ils voient ce
qui se passe dans le marché il voit
toutes les espèces sont menacées aussi
mais ils ne font rien ils ne disent rien
ils n'arrêtent pas les chasseurs
et je vais vous dire ils ne connaissent
parfois même pas les lois ce sujet
et nous en tant qu'activiste quand on
essaye de parler aux vendeurs ou
chasseurs ici ça peut vite dégénérer et
devenir dangereux pour nous
aucun chiffre n'existe sur l'ampleur du
trafic d'espèces sauvages en irak mais
son contrôle des autorités les
braconniers les trafiquants ne doivent
pas être très inventif pour pratiquer
leurs activités
si ce n'est peut-être pour importer ou
exporter ces animaux vers l'étranger aux
frontières ou à l'aéroport de bagdad
certains d'entre eux sont parfois
intercepté comme en décembre dernier où
treize faucons sont apparus sur cet
écran de contrôle
ligoté dans une valise mvm d'arc le
trafiquant avait enrôlé les oiseaux dans
du cellophane puis les avait cachés dans
son sac et leur avait injecté un
anesthésique pour qu'ils ne bougent pas
ils ne fassent pas oui on les a repérés
sur l'écran lors de la fouille du sac
voici les photos des animaux transmises
par les agents des douanes le
contrebandier de nationalité irakienne
prévoyait de les vendre à dubaï selon
ces autorités sur le marché noir le prix
de ces rapaces peut atteindre plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'euros donc les
trafiquants sont des chasseurs
spécialisés ils font ça pour l'argent
mais aussi pour le plaisir comme un
hobby pour tenter de limiter un peu plus
ce trafic le pays a ratifié la
convention de washington en 2014 un
texte international qui régule le
commerce des espèces menacées et qui
oblige les vendeurs et les acheteurs à
obtenir un certificat pour prouver que
le transfert de l'animal ne nuit pas à
la survie de l'espèce des autorisations
faciles à obtenir pour les hommes ou les
cliniques vétérinaires
problèmes dans le pays ces
établissements sont également autorisés
à revendre ces animaux à des individus
sans condition le suivi de l'animal
devient alors impossible
nous en avons fait l'expérience en
caméra cachée à bagdad disant vouloir
acquérir un petit tigre ou un lionceau
[Applaudissements]
pour près de 4000 euros nous pouvions
acquérir un lion blanc menacé
d'extinction personne ne nous a demandé
la raison de cette acquisition ni même
d'ailleurs nos papiers d'identité
résultat comme dans beaucoup d'autres
pays au moyen-orient de plus en plus
d'habitants s'octroie ces espèces
exotiques en particulier les stars des
réseaux sociaux
mais d'autres utilisent cette facilité
d'acquisition pour des activités plus
lugubre un vétérinaire irakiens on a
directement été témoin ait accepté de
nous raconter son histoire sous couvert
d'anonymat on va cause de panne mais
c'était pendant la pandémie promu
j'ai reçu un appel de travailleurs
domestiques
qui m'ont dit qu'il y avait des lions en
très mauvais état là où il travaillait
à nous
[Musique]
ils m'ont dit que les propriétaires
prenait les animaux pour leur tirer dans
les jambes et au grain mons tu les voir
sauter ou courir
que ça les faisait rire
nous lui demandons pourquoi il n'a pas
appelé la police
parce que cette ferme appartenait à un
homme important quelqu'un des autorités
il a su que quelqu'un était venu chez
lui il a fait pression sur les
domestiques pour qu'il lui dise mon nom
et mon adresse puis le monde appelait
ils m'ont dit tu dis quoi que ce soit
cet avis qui sera en danger et celle de
ta famille
du divertissement aux ornements en
passant par la torture ou même la
revente de ces animaux tout semble
possible en irak malgré des lois
existantes pour protéger les espèces
menacées le manque de traçabilité ravi
les propriétaires dans le pays mais
aussi les trafiquants